[Music]
many fans cannot wait until they can
finally watch the upcoming venom let
there be carnage in theaters
we feel the same obviously and in order
to make the waiting time a bit easier
for you
we prepared an original episode for you
this week let's start with the trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
i say either just say either
i say neither and i say neither
either neither neither let's
call the whole thing off
can't stop excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
he says hi one is the loneliest
you and i are the same
[Music]
every decision we ever make
[Music]
who do we leave behind
and how do we leave them
waiting in the darkness of the rescuer
who never comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
[Applause]
soon come chaos
chaos soon come
on
in one scene you can see an unfamiliar
man browsing through the daily bugle if
you slow down the video and pause at the
right moment
you can see a headline about the
avengers on the right hand side as seen
from his perspective
sadly the text is only partially visible
and really cleverly hidden
but this is certainly not just a
coincidence the trailer also reveals an
interesting film location in the
beautiful panoramic view
the ravencroft institute to put it
crudely it's the arkham asylum of the
marvel universe and just like the dc
model
not all inmates leave the institute as
reformed criminals
specifically in vellum 2 ravencroft will
primarily act as the focus of
various scientific experiments most of
which will certainly revolve around
symbiotes and their hosts
there are also some indications that
venom will set the institute on fire
during the course of the film
you can tell it's going to be exciting
another easter egg revolves around none
other than spider-man
well at least a spider and the man in
the scene you can see an unknown figure
killing a spider with his hand
you don't have to be a pro to recognize
that is pretty much carnage himself as
can be seen by his blue jumpsuit after
all
obviously it's clear to everyone which
imagery this clip wants to convey and we
sincerely hope that this is a small
teaser of a big clash between cassidy
and peter parker
even though it's not going to happen in
this movie needless to say there are
many more easter eggs and clues to be
discovered so we'd be interested to hear
which ones you've spotted
post them down in the comments if you
like
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no no you cannot eat mrs chen what
nothing
you